that's the shot you're willing to give
him
james harden flips it up shots good and
the foul
crushed on the backboard
westbrook jump shot is good russell
westbrook
kevin williams double team good help
from hardin deflected and stolen by
mclemore
mclemore a little euro step bank shot
won't go but tips
that's four milwaukee turnovers
westbrook again gets to the rim and an
easy finish
make a miss league it's also a make a
missed call hardin for three
three points well good strip by harden
who has great hands and then
as you retreat in transition his first
field goal
banks at home
westbrook guarded by tarakumbo elbow
jumpers got it
that's team for westbrook if i hear
something in the bush
hardin count it and the foul
[Applause]
and again was the illegal contact
prior to him getting into the shooting
motion
but i mean the strength just to be able
austin rivers tries a three does not get
the bounce to foul
russell westbrook comes flying in and
banks at home
second field goal for korver
hardin for three milwaukee with an
eight-point lead
westbrook able to finish
ball stripped by the rockets here comes
hardin
finds westbrook westbrook up and under
lays it in
then houston has retaken the lead again
great hands on the strip four
on three good bounce pass and a nice
layup